c'est le temps de nouveau gouvernement
conservateur qui va vivre selon ses
moyens et mettre plus d'argent dans vos
poches et à dix jours du vote
et après tout les débats les
conservateurs ont finalement déposé
leurs cadres financiers et du rire veut
équilibrer le budget dans cinq ans la
première année le déficit resterait
pratiquement au même niveau que ce qui
est prévu en ce moment c'est à dire 23
milliards de dollars et des cendres est
ensuite à 15 milliards 10 milliards 5
milliards pour arriver à un surplus en
2024 25 je pose on va le voir dans le
tableau pour atteindre l'équilibré le
parti conservateur vous le voyez donc à
identifier pour plus de 20 milliards de
dollars qui affecte les revenus
réduction des dépenses prévus en
infrastructure 6 milliards 700 millions
de dollars
en reportant le plan sur 15 ans au lieu
de 12 ans on va le voir dans l'autre
tableau s'il vous plaît 5 milliards de
compressions dans les dépenses de
fonctionnement 3 milliards 400 millions
en réduisant l'écart fiscale et la
réalité des rentrées d'impôts notamment
s'attaquant à l'évitement fiscal et
réductions aussi des subventions aux
entreprises et à l'aide étrangère autre
tableau les nouvelles dépenses pour
l'année de l'équilibré budgétaire
s'élève à 11 milliards 700 millions
baisse du taux le plus bas d'impôt de 15
13,75 % le parti prévoit annuler la taxe
sur le chauffage résidentiel également
les prestations de maternité et
parentales seront libres d'impôt et
annulation de la réforme morneau qui est
d'augmenter les impôts de professionnels
comme les médecins et les avocats
voilà maintenant 4e entrevue sur les
cadres financiers ce soir à rdi économie
gérard deltell et candidat du parti
conservateur dans louis saint laurent à
québec monsieur deltell bonsoir bonsoir
pourquoi vous avez attendu après tout
les débats
c'est presque 80% de la campagne qui est
passé pour présenter enfin votre cadre
financier lorsque je vous dirais que
presse les 80 % de nos mesures étaient
déjà connus comme vous le savez au cours
de la dernière campagne au cours des
dernières semaines nous avons fait 24
annonces économiques d'ailleurs la
plupart de ce que vous avez mentionné
tout à leur avaient été faites
précédemment que ce soit l'objectif du
déficit zéro au cours des cinq
prochaines années
que ce soit des coupures très forte en
matière d'international mais également
des deux entreprises s'étaient connus
que ce soit également la réduction du
taux d'imposition et
une série de crédits d'impôt pour aider
les familles pour aider les aînés pour
aider les plus jeunes pour aider les
travailleurs
toutes ces mesures là avait déjà été
connue chiffre est entérinée par le
directeur parlementaire du budget non on
ne verra pas les chiffres pour arriver
au débat et le chiffre principal dans
votre plateforme c'est quand même ce 20
milliards de dollars d'économies et
recettes comme vous dites dans le cadre
financier qu'on peut appeler aussi des
compressions budgétaires à un certain
point sur les infrastructures vous à les
repousser des investissements les faire
passer de 12 à 15 ans ça pourrait
retarder des projets déjà planifié ce
que vous avez identifié les projets
d'infrastructure qu'on va reporter à
plus tard alors tel qu'inscrit dans
notre document est telle que nous
l'avons d'ailleurs toujours dit tout au
long de la campagne électorale monsieur
cheikh était très clair dès le début de
la campagne les annonces qui ont été
faites par l'actuel gouvernement seront
honorés donc aura aucun retard dans les
approches qui ont déjà été faites par
les contrats qui ont déjà été signés
ceci a été dès le départ dès le début de
la campagne
et ceci est honorée comme par exemple
ceux d'intel aux dioula 12 ans donc je
peux réseau là qu'on reporte des choses
à plus tard
ben ce qui a été annoncé va être honoré
par contre oui on se donne une marge de
manoeuvre quand même deux trois ans de
plus c'est pas la fin du monde comme sur
une période de 12 ans c'est quand même
pas finir sur une période de 15 ans
justin la structure c'est important dans
l'économie vous savez comme moi oui
d'ailleurs on se surprend on se déçoit
que le gouvernement qui avait qui s'est
fait élire ya quatre ans dix ans nous
allons beaucoup investir dans les
infrastructures est attendu entre
finalement dans la dernière année pour
faire le lot le plus important de ces
annonces
rappelons la réalité telle qu'elle est
légalement nous on sait déjà qu'on me
concernant certains projets que ce soit
ici à québec pour le troisième ligne que
ce soit en ontario pour le toronto ce
soit en colombie-britannique nous avons
déjà identifié clairement dans notre
document page 98 des éléments pour
lequel une somme commis donc finalement
ce que nous annonçons c'est que week
nous contenons et nous allons continuer
à investir en infrastructures que nous
allons honorer tous les engagements qui
ont été pris par l'actuel gouvernement
même si c'est assez annoncions était
liée et souvenons nous ré où elle vous
l'avez vous même parler aux derniers
mois il ya eu cinq mille 4554 annonce 13
milliards de notre côté nous allons sur
les infrastructures honorer les annonces
d'infrastructures je vous en ai fait le
point sur les dépenses de fonctionnement
il dépense de fonctionnement vous
amplifiée pour 5 milliards de dollars de
différentes réductions dans les
déplacements les conférences
l'hébergement les espaces à bureaux est
ce que c'est le retour de l'austérité
des compressions budgétaires
alors quand on parle de foot optimiser
les efforts qui sont faits par la
fonction publique et avec les dépenses
que l'on peut faire concernant par
exemple le transport les conférences et
les trucs comme ça ça c'est de
l'optimisation c'est pas des
compressions parce que les 45 ans est
écrit dans votre plateforme ne voulait
maintenir les dépenses au niveau de 2019
2020 pendant cinq ans sachant qu'il ya
des coûts de fonctionnement qui
augmentent année après année s'appelle
décompression ça monsieur deltell
la réalité c'est qu'on peut faire mieux
avec l'argent qu'on a et on en est tous
conscients par là n'importe quel
fonctionnaire n'importe quel employé de
l'état que ce soit d'ailleurs au fédéral
ou provincial
oui on serait capable de faire plus mais
il ya beaucoup de lourdeurs
administratives vannes où justement on
veut éliminer et réduire le plus
possible la lourdeur administrative
éliminé que je vous le dise tout de
suite le j'ai peut-être été un mois pour
trop fort parce que c'est un rêve absolu
mais c'est un objectif que l'on doit
tout savoir réduire la lourdeur
administrative et nous on se donne cet
objectif là et on va l'atteindre
et avis aux gens qui nous écoutent qui
travaillent dans la fonction publique
vous ne perdrez pas votre emploi ce qui
vous le dise vous manque pas c'est pas
question pour nous de couper quelques
emplois que ce soit et nous voulons
maintenir justement le nombre d'employés
que nous avons actuellement de les
contempler 5 milliards dans les dépenses
de fonctionnement donc quelque part les
services publics ou en tout cas
l'appareil public sera affecté
bah écoutez c'est votre perspective la
nôtre tels que chiffré tels
qu'identifiés est telle que mesurée
c'est justement de réaliser ces
économies là qu'ils peuvent qui sont
superflus actuellement avec les
technologies qu'on a on peut on doit on
doit s'attendre à voir une approche
beaucoup plus positive beaucoup plus
ouverte et surtout beaucoup moins
dépensière et d'avoir de nouvelles
approches en scène c'est un défi très
fier que l'on lance à la fonction
publique ok parfait donc sa demeure à
identifier des choses qui sont à
identifier dans des insurgés on le dit
clairement sur les transports sur le
petit belge triple audiard je suis pas
dans quoi vous allez couper leur me dit
pas dans quoi vous allez coupé ne viens
de vous le dire monsieur concernant les
dépenses concernant l'optimisation des
bureaux concernant mais les frais de
conférences concernant les consultants
voilà des éléments qui sont noir sur
blanc écrit et on le chiffre à 5
milliards de dollars
vous pouvez porter jugement sur notre
objectif très ambitieux je suis prêt à
accueillir cette observation là mais le
dire que c'est pas identifié je ne
partage pas votre point de vue alors sur
les dépenses en infrastructures c'est
une chose sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est une autre chose et
là vous avez annoncé quelque chose qui
nous vaut c'est à dire que lorsque le
déficit zéro sera atteint vous voulez
lier le salaire du premier ministre et
des ministres au déficit zéro
comment ça va marcher mais soyons
d'abord fait soyons d'abord objectif
notre objectif c'est justement
d'atteindre le déficit zéro si par
bonheur nous sommes capable de
l'atteindre et c'est notre objectif et
nous allons tout faire pour le faire
nous avons compris également que nous
serons dans un second mandat et qui
avait de nouveau défi qui sauve qui se
présenteront à nous il faut comprendre
également que si on veut avoir des gens
qui s'offrent en politique et ça c'est
vrai pour n'importe quel premier poteau
qu'elle fonctionne bien il faut
s'assurer que ce soit fait
convenablement et donc l'antenne coiffé
comme des primes ou des bonis comme dans
le secteur privé
finalement ce ne soit pas vraiment cette
cette formule qui sera qui sera assumée
l'école vous le dit l'objectif c'est
dans les cinq prochaines années et nous
on veut être responsable et réaliste
également nous on trouve que c'est tout
à fait inacceptable de vivre sur la
carte de crédit de nos enfants que
lorsqu'on voit le parti libéral qui
s'annonce pour 100 milliards de déficit
au cours des quatre prochaines années
c'est 100 milliards de factures que l'on
envoie à nos enfants et à nos petits
enfants
pour nous ce n'est pas la bonne approche
de l'environnement on va hériter d'un
déficit pharaonique qui devait
finalement être déficit zéro selon lui
il ya quatre ans les libéraux ont menti
en pleine face aux contribuables ya
quatre ans nous on va être là si par
bonheur les citoyens nous offrent leur
confiance nous allons l'honorer de façon
briard 10e 10 en cinq ans pour le retour
à l'équilibré et un dernier point
monsieur deltell vous allez baisser les
impôts des médecins des avocats des
professionnels vous annulez la réforme
morneau qui avait pour but quand même
d'éviter que des professionnels
constitué des sociétés pourra baisser
leur facture d'impôt
c'est un cadeau aux mieux nantis ce le
18 juillet 2010 cette demeure toujours
une date sombre dans l'histoire
canadienne alors que le ministre bill
morneau et son patron lui justin trudeau
a annoncé une attaque frontale pour les
pme en considérant essentiellement que
les pme bas ce sont des abris fiscaux
pour les mieux nantis et ça
malheureusement j'ai
je dis d'ailleurs à vote à votre nico
c'est pas parce que justin trudeau se
regarder dans le miroir le matin que
tout le monde agit comme il le fait et
ça c'était une attaque qui étaient
cotées c'est quand les pme
il ya des professionnels incorporé comme
dit un médecin avec leurs revenus
passifs avec les avocats notamment on
voulait inviter vite et qui est
constitution de corporations parfait
professionnel pour payer moins d'impôts
ces données mais ces professionnels et
les autres également qu'ils connaissent
des années parfois bonne parfois pour
lui plus difficile qu'il se constituer
un fonds ont été considérés est ce le
meilleur pour tous les travailleurs les
travailleurs autonomes étaient
considérés comme des fraudeurs et cette
approche le libéral était mauvaise et
est néfaste a été condamnée d'un océan à
l'autre et heureusement que nous les
députés conservateurs sous l'égide du
piège est critique car poilievre de
sonner la charge soutenu d'ailleurs
fédération de chambre de commerce ne
prenant que je fais ça un dessin bonne
campagne monsieur deltell aux arts est
ici merci d'avoir été avec nous au
plaisir de vous reparler de s'affilier
au revoir au revoir